if with you all's permission will reduce
the book signing a little bit is that
okay okay thank you I watched her faces
as you talk as you listen to chris and i
watched the the feelings that people
were showing as a clinical psychologist
that's what I do with my life is I am
with people and I look to see the
effects of words the effects of violence
the effects of war of trauma on people
and the message that I want to give that
and bring to you today is one of hope
that the effects of violence are the
same no matter what the cause of
violence whether my career started out
working with men and women who had been
sexually abused who had experienced
domestic violence in the 20 years of my
career I've been to countries where I've
worked with people who have had refugee
experiences from Vietnam from Cambodia
from Afghanistan from Iran from my rock
from Bosnia Serbia Northern Ireland
South Africa Turkey Israel and what I've
seen across across all the cultures is
that the healing components of what can
be given to humans are the same I work
in places like I was in Taiwan yesterday
and I don't even understand the language
but I can see how people can come
together how they can reclaim their
souls that the effects of violence does
hurt your mind hurt your heart hurt your
body hurt your connections with others
and as I traditionally trained
psychologist I was trained to talk to
people to help them make sense of their
experiences but I found that that wasn't
enough that it wasn't enough to help
people just understand some of the lust
for war that Chris talked about some of
the effects of violence the nightmares
the shattering of relationships the
inability to take the risk to trust
again and I became trained in a method
of experiential psychotherapy where I
witnessed with people in groups these
experiences of horror that are replayed
that are not just kept inside the psyche
inside the mind but using teams trained
teams of other psychologists social
workers humanities people that are
joining together with our work now we
recreate the scenes of horror face them
together as a community and find new
ways to come together put new endings to
the haunting images that people carry
around from experiences from internal
experiences of something like incest
between one one person in the family and
another person in the family to the
horrors of war my own experience
includes that a family addiction and
childhood sexual abuse so I come from a
place of speaking from knowing that
healing can happen and again seeing it
time and time again the experiences of
people taking in a group the ability to
try to trust again to speak of their
horrors to put it out and share it until
we can face the violence that happens to
we can really name it and look at it and
speak it without shame speak it without
blame there it just stays stuck it stays
inside the humans and so the the model
that I work with a therapeutic spiral
model is a way of sharing that in
community sharing the horrors so that
you see not just the horrors but you see
the moments of healing and what I've
seen is that in all the places I've
worked around the world the moments of
healing are the same people let down the
defenses
they look in each other's eyes again and
they're willing to take the risk to love
willing to take the risk to reconnect to
find their souls to connect with a sense
of spirituality and to reach beyond the
horrors that are are now being repeated
again as I was flying home yesterday on
the plane I was hoping to get home
before war broke out I was in Australia
on 911 and so I was away from my country
on that day and I didn't want that to
happen again I wanted to be able to be
home with the people that I care about
with the people that care about me to
feel that safety of connection and the
we've started a nonprofit organization
therapeutic spiral international three
years ago and the goal of our
organization is to create teams and
create communities of healing so that
people can come together in this way of
experiential therapy in a way where you
don't just talk and analyze what
happened but you actually use drama use
art use sound and music use expression
to be able to bring back the life into
people as Chris said you lose your
feelings you lose your your humaneness
when you experience violence no matter
what kind of violence it is and if you
can go back to that moment and in and
change it by now reappear ian Singh the
coming together of humans the being able
to go beyond it it becomes an experience
that is more astatically be with other
beings as they're able to risk again
after unspeakable horrors one of the
reasons that talk therapy you know
doesn't work for trauma survivors is
that the horrors that have happened are
beyond words the latest research shows
that trauma no matter violence no matter
how its experience no matter what the
cause of it is it damages the structures
of the brain that unprocessed
the stories that Chris shared the things
that you all have no for yourself that
will see on television in the next few
days damages the structure of the brain
and the the experiences get held in the
emotional centers of your brain stuck
back here and the limbic system it's not
accessible to words there's not a way
into the brain through just talking
about things you have to involve your
body you have to involve your emotions
you have to involve the contact one on
one to another human being to have the
experience that caused the brain damage
the the neurotransmitters to be off to
not work right to be able to shift
around to the frontal cortex so words
could become important again words of
meaning that you have that the sense
that you make so that the mists do get
broken so that you can speak new truth
and can speak about the horrors of what
happens I've seen the shattered psyches
the the shattered bodies and minds and
spirits of the humans that have gone
through the worst experience is
imaginable for many years I listened and
I watched and I heard stories of sexual
trauma and then I started working with
refugees and I found there that the acts
that humans can do to each other the
tortures the religious and political
persecutions are so far beyond anything
that you can truly hold in your mind to
believe happened and then what I saw is
that you can also find the healing for
those experiences i have now witten it
witnessed you know thousands and
thousands of times of people coming
together in community to be able to risk
again to try to find the way past the
horror past the terrors the experience
of violence for everybody is one of
terror
that's the core experience being
terrorized and being helpless that
causes mental health psychiatric
problems such as post-traumatic stress
disorder that wasn't even a diagnosis
until nineteen eighty four even longer
is and centuries of war and and finally
the effects of violence got a name
post-traumatic stress disorder it's and
it's a mental health response a
psychiatric response to real trauma it's
not people making up things that
happened they actually experienced a
trauma the nightmares the flashbacks the
body memories the ways that the trauma
continues to haunt are real they're not
be people being crazy there are people
trying to work through their brain is
trying to work through the old
experiences and I chose the the title
the therapeutic spiral because violence
is like a tornado that's out of control
you have a sense of not having any
control and so the spiral begins to give
an image that people can bridge that you
can choose to spiral and most
importantly you can choose to spiral
slowly and deeply into the experiences
of horror that you want to have healed
and you can spiral back up with new
words it's it's it's not enough to just
you know hold the images they need to be
shared with other people and to slowly
step by step find the ways to hold them
in consciousness so instead of walking
across an enemy line alone in the replay
of it in the re experience of it you
would walk now with somebody playing a
role of a guardian angel of a good
enough mother of your best friend who
didn't die and it doesn't it doesn't
change the reality but what it does is
change the images change the feelings
you get a chance to cry and to grieve
and to and to rage with other people not
to just have to hold it all in
the way Roberta and I have connected is
to to bring the principles of clinical
psychology that I use in the therapeutic
spiral model with the humanities to
bring it even more into the community
you know I've worked with therapy groups
I've worked with large groups of 200
people in South Africa we had you know
men and women mostly women who had
walked seven and eight miles to get to
the workshop because they heard that
maybe there was just something new to
learn about how to help bring healing to
their to their people to their families
and a hunger for that is so huge and so
as I worked with these larger and larger
groups my question became how do you
take it beyond therapy how can you take
it out into the streets the healing that
I've witnessed in small therapy groups
and in groups of people of 25 you know
how can we take it out and reach into
the community and I think the humanities
is the answer for that the the
literature that can come out of people's
sharing their stories the dramatic
performances the creative expressions
that can help people not only share the
horror stories but find the celebration
of the reconnection of being able to
come back together again that the
anthropology is in itself a reason a
support for experiential treatment as
being a treatment of choice for trauma
you know the the traditional methods of
healing from shamans although all over
the world Native American ones Korean
shamans aboriginals they all have
experience at the core of the healing
they do rituals they do ceremonies the
the priests the shamans they take on the
energy of the evil that's being faced
and now clinical psychology research is
showing why that's true why experiential
therapy is the treatment of choice it's
because of what trauma does to the brain
and talk therapy cannot access
is that in the same way I mean if you
want to stay and talk therapy for seven
years and do you know psychoanalysis for
five days a week you'll probably have
that experience because you'll learn to
trust again you'll learn to be able to
connect one-on-one to a human you'll be
able to share your stories but we're
trying to find through through a new
program action against trauma how to
bring it into the community so it
doesn't have to be an elite way for
people to heal how many people in the
world can do one-on-one therapy I mean
it's not even a conceivable idea for
that but how you can bring people
together in larger larger groups to have
new experiences together where they will
take the risk to trust to find faith to
connect with others that that's that's
what I've witnessed and that is the
message that I want to want to share
today you know as I did hear the stories
of horror and as I looked out at your
faces I saw the despair I saw the fear
of us coming into war again of that
becoming now prevalent in our faces but
if we can look it and look at it and
stare it in the face with and really
look at the evil and name it we can I
believe find hope to stop a generational
transmission of trauma that's what
happens you know you have a trauma that
you don't deal with and you don't mean
to pass it on you mean to do whatever
you can to try to make it better for the
next generation but as long as it stays
locked inside it gets passed on it gets
passed on to our children onto our
society is on to our culture that's why
war keeps repeating you know it's not
just the lust for the violence and the
power but is that we don't know how to
do it any differently and so to to help
find new experiences and I've been able
to find that you people do that all over
the world they're happy to come together
in new ways to really find the way to to
become human again to connect with their
own spirits and with the spirits of the
people and I'm not sure how my time is I
think I'm just about at an end here no
that's good it's um I mean it is because
the essence of what I wanted to say is
about the hope I mean you know my book
takes you through step-by-step of you
know how you can practice experiential
therapy in a safe way but that's not
really the message I wanted to bring
here today most of you probably aren't
clinicians some of you may be and the
book is helpful just in in being able to
understand about trauma but but the to
leave you with a message that we don't
have to end in despair that as we watch
the images of the violence that will
occur on the television and will be
impacted by that you can get secondary
PTSD just from watching it on the
television you know in many ways we as
Americans or a very privileged society
and a privileged group of people and
I've seen that as I've gone around the
world and seen the lack of of privilege
and I believe we have a responsibility
as a culture to reach out with messages
of hope I mean if we could only spend
the money that we're spending on the
bombs in humanitarian aid and truly make
a difference but we can only do that one
person at a time so each person can take
their own responsibility for finding
those new experiences whether it's
through a therapy model or through a
community practice or through however
you connect is the message that I hope
to leave you with
all right now we have the terrible
quandary of signing or questions and
what do you guys want to do are you
going to tell me what you want to do you
can ask a question okay I think what
we'll do we have 15 minutes right okay
and i know this is against the rules but
I come from the foundation so i can take
the heat later if this is okay with you
I'd like to have 10 minutes of questions
and then we'll stay a little bit later
to to do book signing is that all right
okay okay okay okay let's
okay I'm really sorry but we just had
all have so much to say okay and no you
guys have questions all right questions
yes sir thank you Chris let me just say
I felt your words with perspicacious and
brilliant true here we are a small group
of people you know get the word out get
the word out but with the immensity of
the media just drowning us how do you
get that word out how do you demonstrate
the more Americans of what that
triumvirate is doing in the White House
the problem in wartime is that it always
begins with the destruction of culture
of our own culture and most effective
the way the state has to accomplish that
is by taking away our language and it
gives us the words in the cliches by
which we speak about the experience
where undergoing so that it becomes very
hard to think outside the box and these
I don't own a television because I don't
want those phrases pounded into my brain
on 24-hour news cycles the war on terror
count down with Saddam showdown with
Iraq once you rob language once they
give us the words by which we have to
speak about what we're undergoing it
becomes almost impossible to express the
disquiet that we feel and I think that
many of us feel we saw this in Bosnia
and in a place like most are where you
had young men who had grown up together
who had gone to school together attended
each other's weddings slept in each
other's houses sitting in trenches off
in a few yards of apart we're at night
they could still speak to each other
killing each other yet they didn't have
the words by which they
could express what it was they're doing
when you ask them why they were fighting
they spat back at you those kind of
cliches that had been that were pounded
into them day after day after day after
day and I'm not picking on the Bosnians
because now we're the same and what it
does is turn the other into an object it
denigrates the other it turns the other
into a caricature and when we go to war
of course the other side is doing the
same so that until you can recreate an
authentic language and that has a lot to
do with allowing authentic culture which
is always about self-examination and
self-critical to again become ascendant
or at least have its proper place in a
society you are rendered mute I think
we've all become in wartime like a
fellow who's so consumed by jealousy
that at the final one of the final
moments before he turns to kill
Desdemona he he says goats and monkeys
goats and monkeys the most poetic man in
Venice a man who would not only his love
but the state with words and that's why
in Bosnia or in Cyprus you do not have
peace you have the absence of war in
Bosnia or with the Turks and Greeks and
Cyprus people learn students learn
different histories both of which are a
lie and this is of course touches upon
the brilliance of the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission in South
Africa where although the torturers and
the killers of the apartheid regime were
given an amnesty to do so they had to
confess their crimes and what they were
doing is returning to South Africans
language a narrative common narrative by
which you can build and maintain peace
and it's always the same disease I woke
up a few weeks after 911 and I looked
around New York with people driving down
the street waving big obnoxious flags
and I thought we've all become the Serbs
and that's what's so terrifying about
war it doesn't matter whether I'm in
Argentina
Israel or Bosnia or El Salvador it's the
same disease and we have it
what my concerns is that we not only
export export war but we import it after
the war is over you bring back a culture
of 300,000 soldiers who come back and
caught of that patriotism is a new cycle
that begins again which means that we
just continue in this you touch upon for
me a very important point and you know
when we look at the destruction of war
we always look at the physical
destruction you take Bosnia which i
covered the bridges the buildings the
infrastructure but probably more
dangerous is that unseen psychological
destruction and one of the benefits that
we as a country have from the legacy of
our debacle in Vietnam is that because
it was a defeat we have not permitted
Vietnam veterans to mythologize the war
the way we have with World War two
veterans they they suffer more trauma
because it because of it but they also
speak a lot more truth about war and I
they have a lot to tell us and we're not
listening it has been done since the
Iliad when Nestor got up and talked
about the age of heroes we look back on
past conflicts we elevate and we and
exalt those that carry out carried it
out the greatest generation and what
we're doing in essence is creating in
perpetuating that myth of war I grew up
in a family my father and all my uncle's
fought in the war one of whom for the
South Pacific he was in the regular army
in 1939 eventually was wounded and never
recovered he never was able to hold down
a job he was a burden on our family was
particularly difficult because as an
alcoholic and and we my father mother
did not drink any he drank himself to
death in a trailer and I don't think
that's an uncommon story that's a silent
story that's what war does
so yes we bring back people who are
maimed and brutalized and then we we
discard them and we don't listen to them
war is always about betrayal it is about
betrayal of the young by the old and it
is about betrayal of soldiers by
politicians
hey uh what would you recommend for
people who are what talking to mike its
00 talking to them oh here I'm okay now
okay yeah people who live alone are
isolated and who are so traumatized that
they can't watch television they can't
read the newspapers they don't have the
benefit of groups like yours what would
you recommend for people like that right
i mean that that's where i see that you
know it each individual human being can
start trying to reach out that if you
find your courage if you can build up
your courage to reach out to the people
that are isolated to reach out to the
people that because of their own traumas
can't even leave their homes to take
that responsibility to be able to to for
yourself to say oh yes i see that person
that's drinking themselves to death in
the trailer yes i see the person who is
you know that looks crazy all the time
and to ask them about themselves you
know to sit two and and just begin the
process of being human with another
person little small things like that or
what can make a difference
of trying to heal people after trauma
and and and and i i'm thinking of
situations like rwanda and mozambique
south africa's not the only model to
what extent have you drawn from
traditional from traditional ways of
healing in in your work but our society
in psychotherapy that right place it
that very much the therapeutic spiral
model we worked with a Native American
shaman for three years in the
development of the model so that we've
incorporated some of the principles of
spirituality of ceremony of ritual of
the the natural ways of people coming
together nonverbal movements dance so
that you know it is in many ways are
returning to some of the aboriginal the
indigenous cultures that I've seen with
the people and where I see that the
people embrace the experiential
methodology the quickest are the
cultures where they're still practicing
traditional healing methods and that it
is about you finding the the public
forum to be able to to confess to own to
to say what the perpetration that have
happened have been you know only then
and that's what the traditional
practices are about they were all
communal you know they were all communal
and they all involved body mind spirit
and connections with both a spiritual
belief beyond something human and the
connections among the different humans
thank you thank you all I'm sorry that
we don't have more time I think we could
probably have this be a seminar yes
vacate this area however at this time
you're watching book TVs coverage of the
Virginia festival of the book in an hour
and a half we'll take you live to
Charlottesville Virginia for a panel on
the limits of free speech during the war
he'll hear from Henry Abraham author of
freedom and the court barber Perry
author of the priestly tribe Robert
O'Neill who wrote the First Amendment
and civil liability and Katherine
McNamara publisher of the online
quarterly archipelago first a family
taped yesterday on reporting from a war
zone featuring charles bowden Amy R
sinski and Robin Kirk
okay let's get started welcome to the
most timely panel at the entire festival
which is entitled the story that could
get someone killed a reporting panel and
you'll notice that all three of the
books that will be talking about today
concern wars in which the United States
has been involved Amy yar senske who is
right here to the right of me is writing
about go for one in her book and the
other two authors are both writing about
and very different different aspects of
the drug war which is both of these
books show is much more than a metaphor
on